a warning this report contains flash
photography
when he left many in number 10 hoped the
dominic cummings drama
was over but it may just be getting
started
do you have any response to that comment
from him he was a close political
colleague
my response is the one i'm giving uh
which is that it was the right thing
uh to to procure those ventilators and
to have that interaction
with dyson in the way that we in the way
that we did but
i think do you think he was the source
i i i don't think people care what they
care about is
uh that's not really an answer what was
what
was i doing back in march of last year
and people have people have attacked me
for that but did you did you finger him
as the source of that league
i don't think people give him monkeys to
be frank boris johnson says the public
aren't interested but labour and the smp
disagree
they want a public inquiry every day
there's more evidence of this state
it is contemptuous and frankly this
attempt by the prime minister to say
nothing to see here nobody should be
bothered with what we're doing is also
contemptuous
the stench of sleaze that is surrounding
this uk tory government now is becoming
quite overpowering there are some very
serious allegations being leveled at
boris johnson by somebody who was very
very close to him
among the barrage of claims mr cummings
has entered the row over how boris
johnson and his partner carrie simons
spent tens of thousands of pounds on
lavish renovations of their downing
street flat
inspired by designer lulu little then
tried to get a tory donor
to secretly pay for it mr cummings wrote
i told him i thought his plans to have
donors secretly pay for the renovation
were unethical foolish possibly illegal
and almost certainly broke the rules on
proper disclosure of political donations
if conducted in the way he intended mr
johnson has now paid the bill himself
number 10 say he stuck to the rules mr
cummings also suggests civil servants
believed
this man tory advisor henry newman
leaked details of england's
second covert lockdown to the media but
boris johnson considered cancelling the
investigation
into that leak because mr newman is a
close friend of the pm's partner
carrie simons if you talk to people here
they
are worried worried about what dominic
cummings knows and worried what
he could reveal next so far there's
little sign from opinion polls
that confidence in the prime minister or
his party is slipping
but the longer this continues the
greater the chance that
could change and local mayoral scottish
and welsh elections
are now just 12 days away boris johnson
says people don't give a monkeys about
all this
but in barnard castle today the town
famously visited by dominic cummings
it seems some do yeah yeah i give him
monkeys
i like boris i think he's doing a
fantastic job
you know things that go on they don't
they think the public don't care what
they do
i've just got the important purpose
through and i will definitely be giving
it a
a great deal of thought this time
department for health was
just a smoking ruin dominic cummings
will be back giving evidence to
parliament next month
it's likely to be another explosive
intervention from the man
some now call nuclear dom joe pike
sky news westminster